[Music]
down to who inherits Hewes estimated
fifty million dollar fortune I started
the magazine on no money
six hundred borrow dollars total
investment of eight thousand dollars on
my kitchen table in Chicago with an
empire that surpassed his wildest dreams
in 2010 half and then fiancee Crystal
Harris showed me around the iconic
Playboy Mansion the beautiful
bride-to-be et has learned Hugh's Widow
crystal was not included in his will it
was certainly a bumpy road leading up to
their 2012 wedding and on Sunday evening
we were watching a movie when the movie
was over I found she was going a runaway
bride days before their June 2011
wedding date crystal told us the legal
process of getting down the aisle scare
her away I'm going to prenup lawyers and
you know lawyers to do a show it just
makes me realize that money isn't
everything and I just needed to be
treated myself she eventually came back
and did sign an ironclad prenup a source
close to the Hefner family tells et they
do not expect a fight because quote
crystal was made well aware that she was
not going to be inheriting anything it's
widely speculated that Hugh left his
fortune to his four children Christy and
David from his first marriage and
Marston and Cooper from his second I
could not ask for a better son he makes
me very proud very close when he
finishes school would you would you want
to bring it over to word et saw the
tight bond shared by Hugh and Cooper now
26 years old he is a carbon copy of his
father at the start of his career and
growing up in the mansion he also had a
sharp business sense when you were a kid
people would drive up they wanted to see
the mansion and you would charge them
you are an entrepreneur and
we age best you know Cooper now serves
as chief creative officer at playboy
we were with him last year just after
their neighbor purchased the mansion for
100 million dollars part of the deal was
that Hugh could remain living there for
the rest of his life the mansion selling
is of course bittersweet because it's my
childhood home that's my daddy's angry
about the house to come today
[Music]
you